I was a child during the war and the
Germans came in to Chuck Slovakia I was
not yet six years old and at that time I
was living in Britain which was the
third largest city things were not
explained to me children at that time
were kept in ignorance of much of what
was going on politically or otherwise
and only when it impinge on actual
family events were some explanations
given I have one recollection of the
German presence of that time which was
when Hitler suppose certainly went
through the town and I do remember my
father saying that I was not to go in
the streets I first remember seeing the
German soldiers just walking on the
street nothing happened much in the
beginning but slowly there was abuse and
the abuse came not so much from the
Germans alone as it came from the native
population the Slovaks themselves I
remember coming home one day and seeing
my mother serving on the star on my coat
and I was aware of the fact that this
was a way of singling us out and I
remember saying let's not do this
because then we can't hide and she said
we have to that is the decree and what
happened in the town itself was there
closing in of the neighbourhood the Jews
we did not have a ghetto and yet there
was and ghetto atmosphere there because
what happened is that certain
neighborhoods where Jews lived which
were more elegant neighborhoods they
were told they had to leave they could
not stay so they had to move into a
smaller and smaller anklet the main
street of which was universe' and I had
always been
child I used to roam around to my
parents despair but so I got to know the
city terribly well and what I would do
in order to be able to continue that
sense of freedom that I had would be
constantly to try to wear a scarf to
cover up the Jewish star and I would
pretend that if anybody addressed me in
some way I wouldn't understand what they
were saying but I did feel that every
exit into the town outside of my
immediate home was in to a very hostile
and dangerous environment that I always
could be found out and I would have
fantasies about what would happen to me
if they found me out and it was always
accompanied by my immediately running
back home to touch base I I the worst
that I ever saw anybody was to get a
very thorough beating and curiously
enough I always expected the beating but
I never received it I never could
understand why and one day I do remember
asking a teacher whom I knew who lived
in the neighborhood as to why everybody
left me alone even though they saw me on
the street and she said to me that's
because you have blond hair
somehow that seemed to me to make me a
little more acceptable but I was aware
of the fact that I didn't want to
identify with the slovaks
and yet I wanted the freedom of the town
which I had gotten so used to and I
wanted to know what was going on because
my parents weren't telling me much and I
wanted to explore and sense what really
was happening and I
the better worst part for me at that
time was watching the transports and the
transport would just suddenly appear and
I remember that we would hear certain
sounds of boots on the street and
usually whenever there was a transport
it was accompanied by 10 to 12 soldiers
coming marching together from house to
harvest and gathering all the people
knocking on the doors and saying you
have an hour people had only an hour in
which they could gather families
together often what would happen is if
the whole family was not together a
child would be sent out to bring in the
rest try to and that used to horrify me
because they would sometimes be a child
who would come running back crying I
don't know where pop is and so what
happened was that there was all these
transports would get together on the
street and the people would hit they're
hoping that the family the rest of the
family would come and eventually what
happened is that which I did not know
because no one ever told me those things
and it was not possible to ask questions
because every time you ask a question
they just give you a slap and what I did
find out was that eventually families
were United at the central post because
when they rest of the family came home
and asked whether they were they would
rush to the police station immediately
give themselves up to the Gestapo and
in 1943 my family decided that they had
to save part of the family they saw all
these transports coming and it was just
a monthly or currents and there would be
2000 people sometimes in the transport
sometimes they'll be considerably less
and we used to live in terror of these
foods and we lived on the fourth floor
in the apartment and my parents were
birth death and I had a deaf sister so I
became the ears I would have to warn
them that the transport was coming and
what I would do is we would all rush in
the back room and when they knocked on
the door we didn't answer we were in the
back room just trying to be as quiet as
possible and what happened is that as a
result of this the responsibility was on
me to always hear what was going on
because in a time I heard ten boots
marching down around the corner
I'd run immediately home tell everybody
to go into the apartment and sometimes
we were together sometimes we were not
and no we used to pray that nobody would
be coming up the stairs just at the same
time and he got so that we all got to be
very very good in spotting but having
this really bad up eyes that looked for
everything and I was the ears and so in
the middle of the night sometimes people
would come up the stairs but there were
no transport collections at night but
they would be what they called
neighborhood spies people who tried to
find out whether the family was still
there and so on and we had to watch out
for that too and I ended up so that I
was constantly listening and what I was
able to identify sounds and but in by
1943 my pal
realized it was just hopeless that there
was no point in trying to live in this
fearful way and so they decided to send
my sister in me to a farm family out in
the country for which they paid great
sums and I had to hide the fact that I
was Jewish and I remember my mother
taking all the stars of my clothes again
and sending me off and this was in this
I would say around the spring or the
summer of 1943 I would I was taken by a
person who was also deaf to his mother's
home in the countryside somewhere in
there near the Tatra mountains at the
foothills and I was introduced as a very
distant relationship was parents we're
in the hospital and second I had to be
taken care of for a certain amount of
time until I got the message to come
back I was told never to tell anyone I
was Jewish I was told that even though I
didn't have to go to church that I had
to pretend that I everything Christian
was very familiar to me and very desired
by me so that for example if their
priest went by I had to cross myself
it used to be terrible to do that for me
because I felt that I was going to in
some way have to pay for this but I
nevertheless knew that I had my sister
as well to take care of who was a year
and a half younger than myself and I
never saw my parents again afterwards in
the spring of 1944 the Sun came back to
the farm and announced to me that my
parents had failed to pay for the last
five months my stay there and
consequently somebody else was going to
take care
of us in Bratislava itself so when we
went back to Bratislava there were
various people we knew who had papers
forged papers and they told us that it
would be impossible for us to they had
the forged papers when we said oh where
are our parents they said they didn't
know but they were still in hiding they
deliver they never told us that they had
already been taken by the last transport
out of Bratislava and finally I remember
one evening hiding on the third floor of
the building which was really the place
where a tailor kept his workshop and we
had to stay out of the place all day
long because he had workmen there and as
he explained to us that those many of
those workmen were very anti-semitic and
if they knew that we were there spending
the night in the dark they would betray
us without a doubt and so I remember
spending the days for three weeks on the
streets going into shops when it I had
to go in going into the church going all
over the place
I remember one episode which was very
harrowing it was when somebody who knew
my parents recognized me and it was very
easy to recognize me at that time
because I am very blond very tightly
curled hair sort of like an afro in
blond and he immediately says come here
I'm going to take care of you and I knew
immediately but I just could not trust
him but my I had lost trust in everybody
I was very suspicious and very careful
to watch and listen for any force or
difficult nerds and I said no I wasn't
going to come and I started to run and
he chased me
and it was a very good thing that my
knowledge of Bratislava came to my aid
because I was able to weave my way
around streets and corners and little
openings in buildings and finally I
managed to lose him I noticed one thing
when I came back to Bratislava that
there were no more transports there were
no more gatherings and the transports
used to terrify me because the speed of
them was so horrendous where they were
trying to force they would yell at the
people and say get out get out quickly
get out gather together
you can't take this suitcase you can
take this suitcase only a little bit
with you no you mustn't take this
blanket and they would just force the
blanket away in the process also there
would be a lot of hitting of especially
of old people and of sick people and
children and shoving and pushing and
there's gatherings of people just
terrified me I really it was a way of
behaving which I could never experience
except in not even in nightmares I even
remember my nightmares as being mild
compared to this but what was terrible
is that it was the behavior - it's the
very people that the Jewish religion
says you must have a great deal of
kindness which I was sick day old and
the children and I saw everything being
done which was supposed to what I
believed in and what I had grown up in
and I remember when I came back to
Bratislava one of the things I noticed
that those transports have deceased so
it was really in one sense a relief but
in another sense a terribly scary thing
because I suddenly realized that I might
be the last one of the few last Jews
left in the town
that they all had been taken except for
the three or four people I knew who were
on forged papers and the thought of
being one of the last Jews was terrible
I couldn't bear it
I kept thinking no I don't want to be
the last one alive and I must have
realized that many of them went to death
because otherwise I wouldn't have said
that I don't want to be the last one
alive and finally after three weeks of
living on the streets being terrified of
the thought of meeting the man who had
traced me again being terrified of
meeting anyone who knew me as a Jew I
had been away from the town for about
nine months so I had hoped that somehow
I am growing I had somehow become less
noticeable but after three weeks of
living like that the man said the people
had gotten suspicious because they found
breadcrumbs and they were complaining
and they thought that the owner of this
workshop had harbored some fugitives and
so he finally told me he couldn't keep
me I had to find some other
accommodation and I took my suitcase and
my sister looking for a place to stay
and I would go to places where I knew
people who were Christians and I knocked
on the door and they slammed the door
right in my face and not saying a word
not explaining just as if I were just a
beggar at the door and they just closed
the door in my face
and finally I went to the home of these
friends of my parents who were living on
the forged Passport and they did the
same thing and then I knew that indeed I
was the last to act there was nothing
for me to do for two days we were
scrounging
had no money we were scrounging around
trying to find food and finally I said
to my sister and we can't lift that lady
but now I on the street so we might as
well just go to the police and I went to
the police and I said my name and I said
my parents name and I said I'd like to
join them and the police were amused
they first laughed and then they
realized that I was perfectly serious
and they suddenly I realized that I had
presented them with a problem they
didn't know what to do with me they
didn't know what to do so they told me
that I could sit on the bench and I
spent the night in the police station on
the bench while they were trying to find
out what to do with me they didn't
explain anything to me
one of the policemen I remember said
well there they are trying to find where
your parents are and they finally must
have found out somehow because it's
immediately put on a truck and driven
into Hungary and that was in serum which
was a gathering point for the last
remaining transports coming out of
practice number because nothing was
going directly from Bratislava I arrived
there to discover that the Prix two
weeks before my parents had been put on
the train to Auschwitz this was the
first time I heard about Auschwitz I
didn't know anything about it and I was
finally put on one train and it was a
cattle car and I in some ways was
terribly relieved to be there because
here I was among Jews again they were
all strangers but still the fact that
they were Jews was very important to me
I was at that time I was nine years old
and I had my sister who was seven and a
half and to whom I had to explain
everything who had to be basically taken
care of because she only knew the sign
language and I could sign with her but
she didn't know how to communicate yet
with their hearing people and so I was
really constantly having to hold her by
her hand so that because I couldn't call
her I couldn't do anything I couldn't
ever lose sight of her because in the
milling of the people we could have been
separated and we finally were put on the
train and I was told that I would be
going to Auschwitz and to me of course
it was just an image of my rejoining my
parents being on the train for five days
and during the whole process of our trip
we would have to stop because there was
bombing going on sometimes the bomb
sounded as if they were very close and
we thought that they would get the train
and we were I would say maybe 300 people
in each car and my sister and I sat on
the suitcase the whole five days that we
were in the Train and at one point the
bombing at one point sounded as if it
were the front of the car had been hit
it was so loud and their carts of jumped
tracks and we were stuck there for what
seemed to me forever and one day as we
were sort of sitting in the car we were
told that we would not be going to
Auschwitz that they would be rerouted
and I remember having to get out of the
car
because it had jumped the tracks and
there was no way for it to move and
crossing the tracks going into another
car then spending another three days in
the tracks they did the Germans did
provide food for us but it was so
minimal it was just a slice two or three
slices of bread and water and that was
all and some of us were so weak we could
barely make it across the cracks to the
other so we had to help each other and
for some strange reason my sister and I
maybe because we were so young we were
somehow had managed to get through the
ordeal of being a two days cooped up in
a very tight space and after about three
days we arrived in Bergen Belsen and
then there was a long march and the
March was the most horrendous thing I've
ever experienced because after eight
days the people just were in no shape to
walk from the station to the reception
house of the camp and there that March
which was seemed endless it was looked
enormous Lee long maybe in my mind now
it seems almost three hours but it
couldn't have been but there we would
slowly walk and the Germans kept
shouting and yelling their work
luncheons and dogs and they would fall
on the people and asking them to hurry
and hurry and I remember the first night
falling asleep I had nothing to eat for
a long long time nothing to drink but I
fell asleep
and I remember thinking
like had played a terrible trick on me
because I was in an Auschwitz with my
parents and I remember saying to myself
as I fell asleep I will never stop
looking for them when we came in with
the transport to Bergen Belsen the
separation occurred in the train station
already so that when we started our
march I already noticed that there were
no men around and no boys and when I
came to look at those transports I
noticed that one of the soldiers we used
to be very irritated with me all the
time especially when I started to ask in
perfect German could I please pull out
my mother's name I knew my mother
couldn't hear me but I thought maybe
somebody with who knew that she was deaf
would tell her that I had been calling
out her name and I would call out her
name over and over again by doing that
one day for that the fifth or sixth time
the soldiers so lost his temper he just
picked me up and flung me against a
stone and I lost consciousness at that
time and the immediate result was that I
lost for temporarily my hearing which
was in some way to me a sense of
tremendous worry because I had to be my
sister's yes I had to hear for her and I
was afraid that I had really had my
hearing permanently damaged but after
about five or six days my hearing came
back later on in Bergen Belsen
I realized that my sister was being
watched by the camp doctor they I do not
know who it was he was a German doctor
but he would come by the children's
barracks all the time come to my sister
pinch
tree Explorer years and try to be very
friendly with her and then one day he
said to me that he would be able to give
us all interesting chocolates if I
allowed my sister to go into the
hospital for a few days and my sister
was perfectly well so I couldn't
understand why you wanted her in the
hospital and I just was very sassy and I
said no you are not because if you are
I'm going to kick you and I went up and
sort of said I am really going to I'm
serious I mean it and so he laughed and
then forgot about it later on the block
has to told me that he had hoped to be
able to use my sister for scientific
research right across from us with a
channel house filled with corpses not
just the inside but overflowing oil that
they were corpses all over
I lived walked beside that people and
after a while it just got to be so that
one noticed and one had to say to
oneself I'm not going to see who with
this
I'm not going to recognize anyone in
this person who is lying there and it
got to the point where I realized that I
had to close my eyes to a number of
things and otherwise I would not have
survived even at that time because I saw
people around me going mad I was not
only having to live with all these
things but with madness
one thing I did receive from the woman
inside was a small bag of tea which I
was able during the time of the typhus
epidemic to exchange for a vaccine for
my sister
and I was told it was a typhus vaccine
whether it was won or not I'm not sure
but the fact is my sister never did get
the typist I did and so what one of the
saddest thing in my life has been that I
have no recollection of the liberation
because I was totally Arabic the Tigris
I have no recollection of what happened
when the English came to bergen-belsen
I was very near death had I had to wait
another two days for the English I would
not have survived and the it's I have
proved it on that that I have not been
conscious at what I consider to be the
most important experience I came to
Sweden I was given over to a doctor in
Sweden who immediately decided to fatten
me up because I weighed at the age of 11
I weighed as much as a three-year-old
child and had a big fat belly
my sister is alive she came to New York
with me she went to a school she went to
the Lexington School for the Deaf she
married she has three children coming to
the United States was a great shock I
happen to come on in August of 1948 it's
the hottest day in the history of the
United States I had come from Sweden I
walked out of the plane and I remember
turning around and saying I'm going back
because not only was it very very hot
but at the airport greeting this plane
which had taken us 24 hours to fly from
Stockholm to New York I was suddenly
faced by a whole panoply of black faces
nobody in Sweden had told me but there
were Negroes in the United States I knew
that they were in Africa but suddenly
come into New York and see all those
black faces I was sure I had come into
the wrong country I was supposed to come
to the United States he was this hot
place with all the black people I
thought that was some way in Africa I
had landed somewhere in Africa it was so
hot that's right it was exactly it was
it was my having in some way sense that
life is playing tricks on me all the
time that I wasn't going to the places I
thought I was going to and then at the
ramp where my relatives waiting for me
none of whom I knew I had never met them
they had all left long before I was born
they were yelling and screaming grenade
and Aron a so I knew that I was where I
was supposed to be but what was strange
was having to get adjusted not only to a
totally different mirror but to
relatives are got absolutely no inkling
of
you